movies was my babysitter when I was a
kid a lot like my dad would drop my
brother and I off at the movie
centerplex and we just watch you know
one after the other every movie in the
whole movie complex and there was a
while I remember like probably I was 12
or 13 that any movie that was on like
HBO or Showtime I could say within like
three seconds which movie it was I'd
probably seen it cary fukunaga director
of beasts of no nation this movie took
several years to come to the big screen
was this a passion project for you
absolutely I've been working on this
subject
not even I started this film for over 15
years it was about my third year in film
school when a friend of mine gave me the
book beasts of no nation and it was so
simple and so and just hard
obviously digest but just impactful
someone like it just met how helpful was
he onset particularly working with the
kid
I mean interest interest was very much
living the role of commando on say I
wouldn't necessarily call him always a
method actor but he stayed there and so
it wasn't like him and a GUI would be
joking around I dunno when you're
shooting a film that you know is gonna
be day and date on Netflix and in the
cinema do you think about it in a
different way that people watch it on a
small screen I think the trend now is
shoot at how you how you think it should
be shot whether it's for the big screen
or for the small screen because even for
the home viewing experience people now
with their home theater systems and the
size of their screens it's almost like
they're in the cinema thank you so much
for joining us here Carrie quick Onaga
from beasts of no nation emulation
Alliance our founding and movie clips
but